28 mai 2010 cette phase finale de
fédérale 3 à houilles plaisir ça sur la
montée en division supérieure
après les festivités retour sur les
terrains
les seniors du plaisir rugby club
préparent leur saison en fédérale 2 une
préparation menée par deux nouveaux
entraîneurs sébastien roncalli et
nicolas lafon objectif pour le promu
le maintien on verra comment ça se
passera on se met pas de barrières en
tout cas on est on a une philosophie de
mettre un maximum de volume de jeu en
place donc voilà on jouera en jour à
100% tous les coups et on verra après
par la suite si on peut espérer autre
chose c'est un gros challenge évidemment
surtout quand on voit la qualité de des
équipes de la poule
maintenant le groupe a connu deux
montées
donc il a quand même une bonne dynamique
une bonne dynamique sur laquelle le
collectif peut se reposer
peu de mouvements au sein du groupe la
continuité règne au sein de l'équipe
seuls quelques changements sur le
contenu des entraînements et la
philosophie du jeu
on met beaucoup d'intensité à
l'entraînement on a rajouté avec
quelques séances et les maxi colle
vraiment donc tout le groupe dans
l'ensemble est motivé pour faire le
mieux possible
donc on est vraiment sur ce travail là
sur du mouvement général est vraiment
renforcer les repères des joueurs quoi
sur les jeux de relance ou tout ce qui
est stratégie voilà renforcer vraiment à
la stratégie au niveau du de l'équipe
la touche roncalli la faune pour mettre
en harmonie le jeu du prc une partition
que devront suivre les joueurs pour
espérer le maintien en fédérale 2